the Lakers writer for the athletic
joining us on the program good morning
bill how are you mornings and I
understand where I fit in on the
hierarchy Friday absolutely comes first
The Godfather of meat and then you okay
our priority list okay let me start with
this simple question are the Lakers a
good team is sometimes an acceptable
answer because we've seen this many
times where the Lakers come out and win
pick games then turn right around it lay
an egg the next night I mean you go back
and just just right before the all-star
break they pulled off pull the rabbit
out of that that they had in Boston when
Rondo hit that game-winner and then go
out and lose to Philly and then
completely collapse against Atlanta
right before the all-star break so we've
seen this a few times the Lakers where
they put together performances that seem
to indicate they've figured something
out only to then completely reverse the
narrative and look like they're
completely in disarray so it has the
potential to be a good team they're good
team in moments are they good enough to
win the number of games it'll take over
the final 24 games to get into the
playoffs I don't think there's any way
of knowing that after after what we've
seen so far this season
even with an encouraging win like last
night the amazing part is they are able
to beat the teams ahead of them in the
Western Conference standings including
the Golden State Warriors they have
beaten all of those teams but then they
lower themselves where you don't beat
the Knicks you don't beat the Hawks you
don't beat the Wizards like you're their
season could come down to what they
didn't do who they didn't beat and then
you've got a five-game road trip coming
up in mid-march so I'm that's what's
surprising is they mail it in against
bad teams but they step up when it comes
to good teams and we saw that last night
against the Rockets how do you explain
that I mean I think you have a little
bit of it where you got a young team a
lot of guys have been to this position
before
perhaps they get a little complacent
knowing they have LeBron James knowing
that LeBron is is is going to you know
do something a little special when it is
a national TV game or it is a game
against another superstar or the top
team in the Western Conference at least
the way they beat the Warriors on
Christmas I think when we left the arena
on Chris
tonight after their win against the
Warriors not knowing how severe at that
point
LeBron's injury was going to be they
were 20 and 14 and looked very much like
a top half team in the Western
Conference they proceeded to go six and
11 over the 17 games abroad so it it it
has been a theme of this season and if
you look at their upcoming schedule the
final 24 games there are a lot of games
against teams you would expect them to
lose to you twice against the Bucks
you've got Toronto Boston the warders
jazz twice those are games that on paper
rationally the Lakers should lose but
they've also been games where the Lakers
have found ways to get a positive result
the question is what are they going to
do when they go play the Bulls what's
going to happen when Charlotte comes to
town those are those are trap situations
that that I don't think you could I
don't think you can confidently say the
Lakers are not going to fall apart in I
know what your answer might have been to
start this season but I'll ask the
question now with 24 games to go is
making the playoffs a successful season
for the Lakers yeah I think at this
point it'd be a relative triumph just
because of the take LeBron out of the
equation for 17 games the number of
games Lanza fallers missed Brandon
Ingram missed a couple of weeks in an
ankle sprain plus foot games he missed
with the with the suspension Rondo has
had two injuries so I think the lack of
continuity be just incredible amount of
off court drama starting with magic
Johnson criticizing Luke Walton but six
games into the season followed by local
team looking wanting Anthony Davis
wanting Carmelo Anthony the noise of the
trade deadline - completely disrupted
the locker room I think all of those
factors if they could get into the
postseason right now I think it would
have to be looked at is that the success
relative to where they've been but
relative to where they should have been
relative to what expectations of LeBron
James are it's not it's not good enough
but it I think it would at least placate
a lot of the critics that will come out
of the woodwork if LeBron is unable to
get the Lakers to the playoffs in his
first year at LA because that is going
to be that will be the ultimate talking
point if LeBron James
makes the move to Los Angeles you know
for his final chapter and is unable to
get the Lakers to the postseason I don't
know if that I don't know if that
tarnishes his legacy in the big picture
but it certainly would tarnish his
legacy of Los Angeles he's built Orem he
covers the Lakers for the athletic
you're around this team on a daily basis
you see them you body language I'm just
curious what that locker room is like
for these younger players that they know
their days are numbered they're not sure
who's gone but somebody's gonna be gone
in the offseason do you do you get that
sense that it's there in that locker
room with these younger players and you
certainly did before the all-star break
and right coming out of the trade
deadline that last night in Atlanta was
was a really tough locker room to be and
there was not there were not a lot of
talkative guys over the tile kuzmic did
talk quite a bit to talk about you know
how they needed to start playing for fun
again and just is it there was a sense
kind of an entire build up to the also
to the all-star break and through the
trade deadline that those those guys
weren't valued anymore that they that
there was very clearly a little LeBron
James and then the rest of the team that
work that was placeholders for whatever
group was going to come in next whatever
was you know a you know some combination
of all the all-stars he had just drafted
to his fantasy Peter's who is a there's
all-star team or some other combination
but you know I mean look I mean players
get to come up and trade trade
conversations all the time there that is
not new I think what was new and
especially for the young guys was to
turn around and look in the locker room
and know that there's a guy on the other
side of the room who has it has a hand
in this and and while LeBron might say
he tried to stay out of the fantasy
basketball side of it that you know he's
just a player there is the dots are too
closely are too close to each other to
not connect them when you have rich Paul
Anthony Davis the relationship rich Paul
is cultivated with the Lakers front
office and Magic Johnson the desire to
additional superstars so it's hard to
it's hard to know what kind of trust
there could actually be in that locker
room but I will give the team credit
with the way they've come back from the
all-star break and the way they came out
against Houston
if they're going to make the playoffs
and they may not still I mean that is a
long a long road ahead final 24 games
currently at 29 and 29 if they are going
to make the playoffs that was kind of
statement Wednesday B's would make
coming out of break what if the Lakers
traded LeBron to the pelicans for
Anthony Davis it's my favorite
hypothetical and I I wish more people
were talking about it Dan so thank you
for giving me this platform I mean look
if they'd trade thing if the pelicans it
had said no to every other offer and the
Lakers came back in the 11th hour and
said we'll give you the Bron James is
New Orleans really saying no and then
you have Anthony Davis all your young
guys and all the cats faith yes that you
that you did now you could get kawaii
now you can get Kevin Durant I love that
hypothetical but the Lakers the Lakers
are way too loyal and the Lakers
appreciate too much what LeBron what
Willa Braun signing on with them in the
summer symbolized you saw with the
contract they gave Kobe Bryant this is
not an organization that would ever do
that but as a hypothetical and as a
mental exercise I love it well we're
gonna we're gonna test their loyalty
because I don't know what Luke Walton
can do to keep his job yeah I on that
front I think you're correct it's I
think I think I think the loyalty
probably was magic not winning out and
being able to fire him at some point
this season I mean is the worst kept
secret in the NBA that LeBrons LeBrons
team has been making noise about Luke's
job magic I think if he'd had his way
would have gotten his own guy in there
already so GE bus has has fought a good
fight to keep him in there through this
season he's not gonna get fired by the
end of the year it's too late to make a
change anyhow so he's gonna be able to
complete a third full year but said I
mean that's the full expectation with
everyone I talked to around the team and
around the league is that but they will
make a replacement at the end of the
year but I mean listen considering all
everything that has happened with this
team Luke Walton has done a good job he
is not the is not the you know the
tactician or X as a nose guy that they
you that certain teams might might might
look for but also LeBron James has never
responded to coaches who are like that
so I actually think who deserves a lot
of credit for the job he is
and keeping this team together the young
guys continue to buy into what he is
what he's been preaching and I think
he's done a good job of managing LeBron
in his minute so Luke may be a free
agent at the end of this year but I
don't think you can look back at his
Lakers tenure and say that he he you
know let the organization down this was
a really tough hand he's been dealt yeah
I'll leave you with this best guess not
that will record this and play this back
for you but Seton are we rolling on this
rolling okay
best guess the second best player on the
Lakers roster to start the season next
year will be oh man Brandon Ingram I'm
not I'm not sure I'm not sure they're
getting anybody this summer I don't know
I don't know what that was well they
don't get anybody I mean I don't think
anybody anybody in free agency and then
isn't the question is who are you
willing to trade these guys for who's
going to trade with the Lakers Bradley
Beal if Washington was willing to engage
would be an upgrade for anyone they have
if they could go get either of those
guards from Portland they were it's
morning drive in Los Angeles people in
the 405 are going no no I mean
fortunately they're not going fast
enough
okay real Davis thank you Bill I
appreciate your time thanks for having
me Dan that's a bill Orem he writes for
the athletic it covers the Lakers for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]